A person's strengths are often their
biggest weaknesses into.
That also means that their weaknesses
can be their strengths.
I am weak in all those ways that I
listed.
I am,
but I don't accept that.
I don't accept that I am what I am and
that that
is what I'm doing to be no,
I don't accept that.
I'm fighting,
always fighting.
I'm struggling and I'm so hot.
Wrapping him,
kicking and clawing at those weaknesses,
the cheap stock though,
some days I win,
some days I don't,
but each and every day I'd get back up
and I move forward
with my fist clench toward the battle
toward the struggle.
Hey,
this temporary,
it may last for a minute or an hour or
day or even a year.
What?
Eventually it will subside
and something else will take its place.
If I quit,
however it will last forever.
I go dot.
Because you feel in the loop,
hey,
at the end of pain,
a success,
I fight with everything.
I've got to overcome those weaknesses
and those shortfalls and those flaws
as I strive to be just a little bit
better today
than I was yesterday.
You got the best two jobs in your life,
you've got your dream job would.
This is only the beginning.
This is nothing here.
This is not where I want you to be for
the rest of your life.
Hey
is temporary.
I've been trying to get that into your
spirit.
I've been trying to get you to
celebrate.
Hey,
are you hear me?
I'm trying to get you to have an
understanding that hey is your friend.
The pain is going to take them to the
next level.
It's not your circumstances or your
seat,
your whites,
it that determines if you're going to be
successful up.
I've been telling you what's your
mindset?
Okay?
Totally.
You want to pay.
I'm not what you feel it.
I know exactly what I've been there.
I've done that,
but you gotta work through it.
Well,
on the other side is the reward.
Listen to me.
Hey,
they permanent,
no pain,
a permanent.
You can get through this.
You're wiggling your pack.
I use the pay to push me to greatness
and I'm telling you right now,
don't give up.
I'm telling you right now,
don't get me.
Get through it.
And if you can get through it,
if you can work through your pay,
I'm guaranteeing you on the other side.
I've got to commit my very being to this
thing.
I gotta,
I gotta breathe it.
I got to eat it.
I got sleep sweeper and until you get
there,
you'll never be successful in life.
Well,
once you get there,
I guarantee the world is yours.
Once you make yourself one single
mom,
it's too self ever.
Then you can go watch your life become
you actually want it to be.
Because the very best for human beings
is one that lives in the line.
Your thoughts,
your words and your actions all as one.
Yeah.
Not One day saying one thing and then
off the next stage,
doing something else.
Thinking and wishing so badly that you
could have something for them only to
give up on yourself before you even
tried.
Plus you have to hope that good things
will happen to you when you cannot trust
yourself.
You can't rely on your own capabilities
and the fact that you will show up and
do what you said you would.
Of course you're going to rely on luck
and chance.
But if you build up your belief in
yourself,
keeping the promises that you make to
you,
your life will change instantly.
I'm not talking about an agreement that
you made with somebody else.
I'm love talking about a contract
and we don't need anybody expecting you
to keep your word for somebody else
until you have done it for you.
Why should anyone else ever believe in
you?
Why should anyone else ever trust in
If you cannot trust your son?
See the moment that you actually start
doing the things that you said you
would,
the moment you start actually acting on
your ideas is the moment your life
changes flow ever.
It's the moment where you access to
power them.
Most people never experience in their
lifetime.
You gained the power to make anything
that you want.
Anything that you dream of become
reality.
Because when you follow up your
thoughts,
when you follow up a dream with real
action,
well then nothing can stop you.
Nothing can get in your way.
Nothing can really take you from your
goal and absolutely nobody can take away
your goal from you other than yourself
is when you don't follow through speed.
Don't do the things that you said you
would do that other people start to
disappear in fail too.
We were talking about your dream here.
We're talking about your passion.
We're not expecting everybody else to
show up and give us handouts.
You give yourself a handout by following
through with actions that you said you
needed to do,
that you know you needed to do that no
will take you to the next level.
So stop treating your word like trash.
Stop treating it like garbage,
like something you could just throw
around saying one day that you can
improve your relationship.
They seem that you're going to be better
socially,
but saying that you're going to make
progress in your career or that you're
going to lose weight and get in shape
and then the next day not do anything
about it and just give up on yourself.
Even if you went half way there.
It's the same damn thing.
Go all the way followed through with
real work,
real effort,
cause you can keep daydreaming and
escaping your dream.
You can keep thinking that one day we'll
be real or you can actually step into
it.
Today you can make a real decision.
I'm real life position,
not a fantasy,
a real choice to no longer daydream,
but to use your name,
to step into your dream.
I heard my own trusted you.
This no one else can approve of you
except for you.
You have to validate your dream.
You have to validate your passion and
you have to validate it with real work
and you have to follow with passion.
We'll drive determination and all such
thing as giving up.
How about you stop looking for other
people scanning?
What's,
what's your guarantee success?
What's your guarantee about reaching the
point where you want to
take you seriously?
No,
seriously stop letting yourself now
because there is absolutely nothing,
nothing in the world that feels better
than doing what you said you would.
Problem is everybody wants to be obese
and so it's time to do what real bees
do.
Everybody gets excited.
He t the bull story,
but nobody wants to get up at three
o'clock.
Well,
I was excited when I say I wake up at
three o'clock three o'clock
hi.
Well you walk out of here,
popped up,
fire it up.
Who get some new information?
You're ready?
Everybody wants to be a beast.
It turns time to do what bees do.
Okay?
What's you have to understand is
everybody that you're going to hear from
Eric Thomas.
My mother got pregnant with me at 17
years old,
high school dropout,
ate out of trash cans,
going to bed and building,
slept in cars,
multimillion company.
That's changing the world.
I didn't say America.
The world.
Why?
Because not only do I want to be a
beast,
if you follow my 24 hours,
I do what bees do.
You can't just say you want it.
Yes.
Can't watch the video and say I want it
as bad as I want to breathe.
It's true to say it
when the sun comes up,
you've got all the books,
you've got all the tapes,
you got all the access.
Now it's time charts.
[inaudible]
I haven't is essentially a decision that
your brain made at some point in that
you made
and then you stop making but continued
back.
I'm sure you've heard that cheesy quote
about life being a journey.
Well,
it's absolutely you're not racing
anywhere.
She slow down.
Stop looking around at what everyone
else is doing and focus on where you are
and what's important to you.
Okay.
We know from neurological studies and
every habit has three components.
There's a cue,
which is like a trigger for the behavior
to start and then there's the behavior
itself and then finally a reward.
And for years when people thought about
habits,
they focused on the VP.
But what we know from all of these
experiments is that it's the queue and
then we'll warm.
What are the secrets to unlocking a got
understanding how it works and more
importantly to change it.
How do you gain for assistance and how
do you start to have more good days than
bad days?
You're going to hate this advice,
but it absolutely works.
You must come up with a morning routine
that you do every single morning or at
least more and mornings than not.
That puts you in control of yourself
then in control of your day.
Okay?
We can choose.
We can choose to create new habits.
We can choose to extinguish old habits.
Once you understand how they work
according to studies,
you get to reshape these automatic
behaviors and then you gain this control
over these parts of your life that
otherwise just feel sort of just at the,
just out of reach
and foremost,
wake up on time when that alarm goes
off,
get your butt out of bed.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one go.
Why is that important for persistence?
The reason why is because the first
decision that you're making of the day
is to actually get up and get moving.
Yep.
Means you are persistently bigger than
your excuses.
You are persistently vigor than feeling
lazy,
and you are persistently feeding the
feelings that typically stop.
Yeah.
Where it is that your two priorities are
in your head.
Why?
The reason why is because of
persistence.
Yeah.
You got to
start off your day by getting up on
time,
figuring out your priorities,
and then getting to on them.
Single biggest reason why people have
bad days is because they start them off
by looking around at everybody else and
seeing what they're doing.
Instead of having the focus and the
discipline
to actually start your day off with you
in,
in troll,
get out
one time,
figure out your priorities and exercise.
You've got to believe in yourself.
You've got to believe in your abilities.
You got to believe in your service,
your company,
your ideas.
Unquestionably,
you must have faith.
It's hard.
Yes.
It's difficult.
Blight,
and it's worth it.
Okay.